estava viajando e aí galera que a sinaga
naldo vocês a totti que acabei de uma
mijada muito boa onde o coisa boa no
mundo é mídia e pagar e comecei a ter
carga e comer o que acabou de comer a
digerir e carga e é muito bom mais uma
vez gravando em hotel vou fazer um show
aqui em joão pessoa na paraíba e os
próximos shows é campina grande de 22 e
natalia a dia 23/1 então se você é de
campina grande em natal é só você olhar
essas informações estão aparecendo aqui
na tela agora ó comprar seu ingresso e
hanói filho um vídeo umas semanas atrás
sobre término de namoro e fala das
coisas que acontecem quando você termina
um namoro eu tinha falado isso porque um
amigo meu tinha terminado o namoro só
que agora o tal amigo meu começou a
namorar e eu comecei a observar as
coisas no começo do namoro a pessoa
puder se apaixona a pessoa deve se
apaixona se transforma totalmente a
pessoa é hulk irassoque feliz apesar do
rock afro do rock a aí a pessoa se
apaixona por outra pessoa quando você
vai ver agora se já em ligar marote em
arenito na guiné euros irá é isso aí tá
escutando e você está escutando aí e hot
por eraí deixou viu que tal viesse roque
oferece solta e amigos
não é só fado dando e fogueteiro né
estou ficando aí mas aqui não é favor
não é uma banda nova que surgiu é saco a
2 do rótulo você já pensou que ela é de
um jeito ninguém faz ela mudar do nada
ela muda certeza que é mulher no escuro
o cara diz o brasileiro o ramo larga
esse brasil nunca quer que brasil
navegará no teu que faz da dor mesmo
para postar foto em londres ea mulher
meu amor te amo todas as minhas forças
eu faço qualquer coisa com você até a
mulher diferente do começo do amor
porque a mulher no começo do namoro é
mais exigente do que o cara já avisam o
cara é o medalhista olímpico medalhista
de ouro em salto com vara sincronizado e
2013 pequim 2004 na de ouro do município
edson gomes e medalha de ouro do mi7
bronze foi do bronze 2008 perder o
domínio medalha de ouro 2010 metade 8001
verdade o 2012 medalha de prata tinha um
cara nem correr pra [ __ ] nem e aí
conseguiu dormir 14 verdade o 2015 e vai
disputar a última último salto com vara
sincronizado no mundial de jogos
olímpicos da tailândia é a última
disputa dele a disputa dele caiu bem no
dia 23 de agosto uma grande coincidência
por dia 23 de agosto é meu show em natal
em que quiser comprar ingresso no
primeiro link inscrição do mar no dia 23
de agosto também é o casamento da prima
de terceiro grau da menina que namorava
um mês que a mulher faz ela dá um apoio
para ele fazer limpezas não ela
aproveita que está no começo do namoro
abusa do poder diz assim a moto vai
deixar de ir para o casamento da minha
prima pai ganhou na verdade o amor
prêmio de terceiro grau nem conhece sabe
meu deus ao mundo não tem coração não é
um casamento momento melhor na vida de
uma mulher é caro a multa disputar minha
última medalha de ouro cada peça olhada
e tanto medalha de ouro não quer mais
que deixa de ser egoísta quarto a descer
do helleva cara meu nome é totalmente
insensível foi como é que toni uma
mulher dominar tanto caro e quem é que
vai ganhar melhor de outro cara solteiro
porque isso aqui papai mas não se tem
uma coisa que freia o homem ea mulher
para quem esse casamento é tudo bonito
você apoia tudo você gosta na mulher e
acha tudo lindo
a marcha [ __ ] traficando drogas na
esquina na liga mané fofa desgraça de
manhã a imma como fofinho a dançando
funk passando por equipe no poste mas é
lindo demais
agora vem a mulher quando o cara faz
isso ela vê o cara fazer algo diferente
que ela disse eu não te conhecia assim
cara nunca te reconhecendo a loja já que
o celular ea música no celular
o cara tá solta de bocha e sua música
própria nem por isso é que eu tô na pa
goiano pela rua da balada quando começa
a namorar menino mas jorge mateus entra
na vida da pessoa com uma força tão
grande o toque da mensagem foi a música
running é ensiná pique o topo da chamada
o meu amorzinho em um cara tá tomando
banho namorada ligou até aparecer jorge
mateus do bunheiro um caso eu tô na hora
que a pessoa começa na hora para dar um
derrame na boca não fala direito mas nã
o hã hãe a ele nem gente querendo de
sheila a moderna porque se é na pista
dela é meu nem imc big dom cheney a bug
bebê ea criança olha a pessoa fica meu
deus o tanto que eu queria falar direito
e um idiota falando igual eu acho que
todo mundo que começa a namorar namorar
agora é a minha linha é já na pista é
uma manchinha o time tinha bush não há
mocinho não esquece que é de campina
grande natal fechou e deu em 2003 para o
erê vinhedo e são paulo é o final de
semana todo e só de vocês é só entrar no
meu site que está aqui na descrição do
vídeo comprou ingresso no mundo para
visitar meu site é o primeiro nem a
descrição do vídeo é só clicar se vai
ver todos os shows belo horizonte
salvador minas gerais ceará e 4 se você
tiver gostar do vídeo game boy vale
gostei aqui volta lá no facebook essa
postagem eu puxei vídeo não sei se clica
e marca seu amigo e começou namorou que
foi assim quando começou o namoro se
inscreve no canal para não perder nenhum
vídeo comenta aqui em baixo como é que
foi minha coisa pra fazer com ela começa
aqui em baixo como foi o seu começo de
namoro no começo do namoro seus amigos
valeu é nóis um cheiro a leu é nóis
feira vou fazer um show aqui em joão
pessoa andando fora aqui tá ligado meu
irmão